well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor of huffpost uk kevin schofield
and the sun's deputy political editor
kate ferguson they will be with us from
now until just before midnight welcome
to both of you so as ever to the front
pages starting with the guardian it says
the jubilation at the lionesses victory
in the european football championships
is echoing around the nation
referring to the onstage choreography in
trafalgar square today the metro calls
the teams dancing queens
world at their feet is how the sun puts
it
meanwhile the telegraph reports on the
endorsement of liz trust by her former
rival penny mordant the paper also
carries an editorial on its front page
giving its support to the foreign
secretary
the express has mistrust once again
setting out her stall as to why she is
the best candidate to deal with taxes
the daily mail zeroing in on her plan to
ditch uh so-called junk food tax
the eye hears the retentions between
some tory mps and the outgoing prime
minister apparently they believe boss
johnson is a narcissist while he
believes them to be neurotic
the times reporting that british airways
has suspended sales of short-haul flight
tickets from heathrow in another blow to
already frustrated holidaymakers the
international edition of the financial
times has word of us house speaker nancy
pelosi's intention to meet the taiwanese
president despite china's warning that
doing so would result in repercussions
for the american government and on a
very different note and i'm not sure
what note at all if i'm frank with you
the star has the story of a pony uh that
was elected the mayor of his town then
banned from the local pub
who knows what that is about
nightmare it says anyway a reminder that
by scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us so let us
go then to our guests uh kevin scarfield
and kate ferguson
kevin enjoying the stars front page at
least at least you did anyway
but let's um
let's start with you then kevin um the
guardian everyone is buzzing the
lionesses victory echoes around the
nation
what scenes and uh what an
achievement an incredible achievement
and you know i think we'll probably look
back in years to come
as this being base camp really i think
for the women's game in this country uh
the
inspiration i think that the victory and
will provide for lots of young
uh girls young women now going forward
you know and so who knows where the
women's game will be in
10 15 20 years time i've got two two
daughters myself they're not massive
football fans but they were pooping and
cheering yesterday watching the game
which is just fantastic you know and if
that was replicated all over the all
over the country not just england but
across the whole of the uk then i think
um you know the future is very grateful
for the women's game right across this
country
and they've proved so much haven't they
kate you know first of all how fantastic
women's football is at that level that
they can fill a stadium despite being in
smaller grounds around the country often
and inspiring people everywhere you know
young children to you know people who
find that women who not doing sport
anymore as we saw in a report just over
a week ago
yeah exactly i mean i think the whole
country was watching yesterday weren't
they as we finally
um wanna want a final
it i think kevin's right i think this
could be a huge turning point for the
women's game there's this stat that's
been trotted out quite a lot this week
which certainly rings true with me which
is i think it's about
half of a secondary school girls don't
even get offered football pe lessons i
know i wasn't offered football p lessons
at school we had to go after school in
year seven to do football so hopefully
this will be a real turning point not
just in watching women's football but
hopefully it will get more people
down the stadiums watching it regularly
but also crucially playing it because
for so long like when we grow up young
girls are out in the park with their
brothers and sisters playing kick about
aren't they but once you get into school
it becomes really segregated and very
gender specific and i think if this gets
like more girls and women into football
then it's a hugely good thing
kate kevin stay there we'll come back
with more on the conservative leadership
hustings but we have some breaking news
uh president joe biden is set to address
the nation
after what is being described or the
white house says was a successful
counter-terrorism operation on an
al-qaeda target in afghanistan
over the weekend let's get some more
from our u.s correspondent mark stone
and who do they say they got their mark
uh well sources uh here in washington
are saying that it is the al-qaeda
leader ayman al-zawahiri if that is
correct then this is the most
significant
counter-terrorism operation as the
americans are calling it since the death
of osama bin laden uh back whenever it
was a few years back my my mind escapes
me at the moment but this is a very very
significant announcement that much
certainly uh being made clear by the
white house who said that the president
will address the nation at 7 30 uh local
time that's happened 12 at your time
tonight so in a couple of hours at time
they they say only at the moment that
that a a counter-terrorism operation has
taken place in afghanistan that it took
place uh over the weekend and our our um
our colleagues at nbc news uh
are saying that two sources um that they
have spoken to have said that it was a
drone strike uh over the weekend uh and
that it killed uh the top al-qaeda
leader ayman al-zawahiri an egyptian man
a man who took over from osama bin laden
uh when he was killed and a man who has
eluded capture um ever since he was
wanted for the bombings uh not in new
york but back in 1998 the bombings of
the american embassy
in nairobi and also in dara salam
involvement in that prompted him to be
on the fbi's most wanted list of course
he was a very senior al-qaeda figure in
2001 during 9 11
number two to osama bin laden and for
the years since osama bin laden has been
dead uh
hawahiri has been the al qaeda leader so
a very very significant announcement
that we're expecting from the white
house in a couple of hours time yep
harper's 12 mark thank you very much
indeed with that breaking news thank you
let's return then to kevin to kate the
tory hustings as i said uh that they are
in the other papers are they not not
least the daily telegraph kate why don't
you pick up on this one um so uh
now penny mordent uh deciding to declare
for his trust and so it seems the daily
telegraph too
yeah this is obviously big news so
tonight we had the latest in the tory
hustings where rishi's facing off
against liz and liz
oh the massive favorite to win the
contest now she wheels out another big
beast penny morden to support her now
penny viewers will remember became third
in the contest and i think actually for
political viewers like kevin and i it
was a bit of a surprise that we saw her
coming out today we didn't know she was
going to be endorsing liz
and the end of that contest had got
pretty bitter between penny's team and
some of liz truss's backers so it is
interesting that penny has thrown her
lot in behind truss you see now that
trusses the overwhelming favorite to get
the keys to number 10. she's had a host
of cabinet big beasts come out in favor
of her
lots of press obviously backing her her
message on cutting taxes immediately is
going down incredibly well tory
activists and i think the big question
really is can rishi stop this train
this train of trust is this kind of
unstoppable at this stage
yes and there's the daily express as
well uh liz trust i'm the real deal on
tax and in the latest hustings that we
saw kevin you know rishi cena was asked
about that was he not and he made the
point that the national insurance
changes were there to try to save social
care and ultimately you know money will
go to the nhs but you know ask directly
about the fact that people are not being
cared for does he need to switch his
campaign to that do you think to i mean
you know how can he save himself now i
suppose i'm asking
it's going to be very very difficult i
think i mean he has in the last week
he's shifted a bit on tax you know
at first he was saying you know we're
not going to start cutting taxes until
the country can afford it until we've
got inflation under control and last
week he said um he would take vat of
energy bills for a year and then last
night came the big announcement that um
he plans to to cut income tax from 20
people to 16 p in the pound by the end
of the next parliament so that's 2029 so
he's he's tacked a little bit further to
the right
on the economy in a bid to try and claw
back this this big lead that liz trust
has got because you know her position
has been as you say very clear from the
very beginning that as soon as she's in
the door at number 10 she will begin
cutting taxes now he has criticized that
strongly i think he's looking at the
same opinion numbers as the rest of us
and realizes that what he's been saying
originally wasn't working so he's had to
shift i'm not sure how credible it would
be for him to shift
even more in terms of tax or to u-turn
anymore and things that he said on the
economy up until now i think he's just
got to stick to the to this strategy
that he's got never seen that he is a
tax cut and conservative but he will
only do it when he thinks that the
economy can afford it whereas liz trusts
he says has taken a huge risk with
inflation people's mortgages interest
rates going up and that i think is just
going to be the message that he's going
to keep hammering home for the next few
weeks but it does look certainly with
all these endorsements that and liz
trust is getting penny modern tonight a
very very big one for her i just think
it's it's looking increasingly unlikely
that he'll manage to come out on top
yeah that was all in exeter uh back here
a reminder of thursday night at k burley
8 p.m we'll be hosting a special
programme with the two candidates the
battle thought number 10 so do stay
tuned to that latest on what we hear
from them and um you know how they try
to push their own campaigns forward
meanwhile back at the mothership at
westminster in the eye goodness me boris
johnson's blame game neurotic tory mps
clash with narcissist pm what is going
on kate
yeah i mean
certainly boris left was leaving number
10 with
rocky relationships to say the leads for
some of his backbenchers this is the
splash of the eye which is talking about
how boris blames some of this 2019
intake for his downfall we know don't
mean that lots of those redwallers did
play a part in that no-confidence vote
that brought boris johnson down
he's hitting out at them apparently or
friends of the pm is hitting out at them
they hit back saying he's a narcissist
it's all a little bit ugly isn't it
we've got quite used to this blue and
blue wall wall rather in this tory
leadership contest but certainly things
are still quite bitter and raw i think
between the current number 10 regime and
some of those backbenchers in a way this
is all almost ancient history now
because there's going to be a new leader
in number 10 in just a matter of a few
weeks and so you know big deal about
what they think of each other really but
um yeah just go to show that whoever
gets the keys to number 10 next has a
lot of making up to do within the party
a lot of different factions and wings to
bring together does does sound so does
it not
kate kevin stay there lots more to
discuss including
more on relations or why relations
between the us and china might be about
to escalate stay with us
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me now kevin
schofield and kate ferguson welcome back
to both of you let's go to the financial
times kevin and this controversial
visit from the speaker of the house of
representatives in america nancy pelosi
to taiwan to the anger of china at this
stage looks to be going ahead tell us
more
yeah it does and it's not just that the
anger of china is concerned from the
white house as well and officially she's
going
as on a tour of asia uh and the taiwan
visit is not part of her official
identity for security reasons but yeah
apparently it is going ahead tomorrow
she's going to meet the taiwanese
president now the white house are a
little bit concerned about this for
obvious reasons they don't want to annoy
china unnecessarily china obviously
claimed sovereignty over taiwan and they
have said america look if you try to
intervene here then there will be
repercussions there's even talk in the
article about what would happen if the
chinese tried to intercept um the ux air
force flight taking nancy pelosi and
her aides
to uh taiwan so and where that to happen
and clearly that would be a huge
escalation the military would need to
intervene to to stop it and yeah we
don't even want to think about that but
yeah so it's a deeply sensitive um issue
to put it mildly but nancy pelosi is
seemingly determined to go ahead and she
would be the most senior
american politician to visit the country
since newt gingrich in 1997 which is
obviously 25 years ago so um yeah quite
a quite a big quite a big deal
kate quick 30 seconds on a massive piece
of space junk that has landed in the
wrong place if i can put it that way
yeah maybe one of the least reassuring
stories in the papers tomorrow um a
farmer in the australian outback has
wandered into his farm and found a giant
hunk of
what was a bit of a spacex satellite
which landed in his uh farm in his back
garden it's meant to have landed in the
ocean safely so yeah look out above i
suppose if you're in the australian
outback yes and the remains had been
orbiting earth's atmosphere since
november 2020 we get our mess everywhere
don't we kate ferguson kevin schofield
thanks to both of you